hannah good to see you
dominic juliet
yes samuel you're it good great
so yeah it's been a great it's been a
crazy week i've just been how do we do
it again
hello everyone oh good good
[Laughter]
great hello everyone
so is anyone got any good news i want to
hear some good news
some deals done hello
somewhere i see you i'm very
how are you brother i'm good man how are
you
how are your service departments going
it's very well
we are surviving okay good
good good well surviving is not as good
as driving but it's it
it's better than losing so well that is
the main thing
what's that sorry we're keeping our
floor
oh good good right here's what i want to
hear
i want to hear someone jump up someone
who's done a deal over the last week
um i want to hear what you've got to say
hey samuel
please mute their mic because i can hear
kids in the background
i can hear all kinds of stuff um but i
want someone to jump up and
and i want to hear someone's success
story so i'm ready can i go
yeah go for it patricia hi everyone
um okay so i put in an offer
i put in an offer for um a brr
hmo it's a possible 12 bed
in um a little working town and
they accepted my below market offers so
um i sent them
my proof of funds my id my solicitor
information
and um so i'm pretty jazzed about the
whole thing
what's the deal talk us through the deal
okay so it's um
three apartments in one sort of building
block um each apartment
has three to four um rooms
um sorry three floors so anyhow so
they're all gonna be
four bedrooms in each of the three
apartments i had an a
a mike took an hmo manager out there
they gave us a quote
the quote came in for the reefer well
below
we talked to council uh they confirmed
we don't need a license or planning it's
not article four so we're pretty excited
about all of that
and um and yeah so um uh
so yeah that's our exciting news and oh
gdv
is probably going to be i i calculated
250 but i put in the calculation
210 just in case because you just don't
know right
um so it's 1 15 to purchase it um it was
listed for 140.
and um renovations are coming in at um
57 000.
um so yeah feeling pretty good so you
bought it for 115. yeah the offer
accepted today did you say oh did you
complete did you complete
offer it was accepted a few days ago
okay awesome so
now it's going through sales progression
you're going to spend 57
on it so all in all you're talking about
what one
so 175 175 and then the gdv on it
is the gross development value is is a
conservative how much
210 210 so when you refinance it even on
a worst case basis
you're going to pull out everything bar
about 15 20 grand
yes and that's you know worst case right
that's and that's worst case so that
anyone that doesn't know
that's the buy refurbished refinance
strategy patricia how did you find
how did you find the deal i think mike
found it mike can find
the best deals so i'm pretty sure mike
found it
um we we viewed it four times um it's
been going on
since early december um and motivated
vendor
the place looked like a total total
disaster i took full video of it
and they didn't even have electricity
when we when we went to go view
um and beautiful huge garden beautiful
deck
um it's on the main road in the town and
uh yeah so we just kind of one step at a
time just took our
you know just made sure that we
connected with mentors asked them
questions
um so so yeah i'm gonna buy it as a cash
deal
gonna do the refurb and then um
refinance get the money out i'll jv with
somebody who has hmo experience so we
can
get approved for a mortgage and then um
and then have a little our first little
hmo we were gonna package and sell it
but it was just kind of too good
that we decided to keep it incredible
well that's another another really good
lesson as well
i mean for anyone that's asking people
are saying who is mike
mike is patricia's husband paul
yeah they moved they moved they moved
from canada to the uk
just like literally a couple months ago
was it was it yeah november first yeah
the first so a few months now and um and
i've been storming ahead you've been
taking advantage of the
mentoring calls i know you've been on
many of the mentoring calls
with everyone right every time because
us mentors we get together sometimes
and and like me tony alastair russell
anthony ricky david and everybody always
says
everyone's spoken to you at some point
you know it's like yeah
but that's a really good lesson as well
you know because
those that those that are unafraid to
ask for help or sometimes those that get
the
get the uh get the results so that's
incredible have you got any
what would be the biggest lesson that
you would share with everybody on the
call
who's looking to find a brr like i don't
know if mike's on the course
what would you say your advice would be
to someone that's looking to find a deal
right now in this climate
yeah i mean definitely the deals are out
there you just
really have to scrape the internet use
all of the software and all of the tools
reach out to everybody um and just kind
of go through it and don't get
discouraged it takes time
even when you view it to when it
completes it's months and months and
months these days so
you just have to stay positive stay
motivated and um
don't take your eye off the ball just
keep going that's great
love that well uh thomas has also just
come on thomas bowen
he says well done patrice that's
fantastic i'd love to talk about how it
went
if thomas is on the court thomas could
you jump on because i think we were
speaking on instagram earlier
and you made you did a deal i think
today if so jump on thomas
patricia massive respect you're
incredible
you're the lady that's you're going to
be on winners on the wednesday very very
soon
so uh massive hats off to patricia um
thomas if you're on the call
it'd be great if you could if you could
if you could
what's happening thomas how are you
doing you look like how are you doing
man just
just ready to go and work out at the gym
or something oh
yeah i know i've uh i just had a bath
and this is where i checked on
so so what's happening with you give us
a load down on what's going on this week
uh yeah so uh i mean this the the
deal that i sold last week for twenty
thousand pounds i ended up refunding
yesterday
time four uh yeah um
it's it's not over with that deal like i
can still sell that deal we've just got
to get a
a couple of builders down there to uh
get some proper quotes done
um uh but yeah the the guy that i
refunded twenty thousand i sold
another deal i so i refunded him
yesterday and then sold him a
three thousand nine hundred and ninety
five pounds
deal today wow brilliant money in the
bank
money's in the bank awesome he's going
to be with tomorrow
right so thomas sold a deal for 20 000
pounds
the deal fell or not fell through but
there was some issues with it
so tom did not hold on to the investors
money
he immediately refunded them at twenty
thousand but boy
twenty thousand pound finders first a
big ass
finders thing i mean if you do if you do
one of those a month
you're good you're good tom
we funded the dude because the deal
wasn't quite as as tom as
tom said there were some issues however
the deal is still
active it's still live tom's trying to
rejig some stuff around to sell it again
but now tom's just gonna solve another
deal made four thousand pounds
profit today in the bank i've seen the
screenshots
tom advice to someone starting out in
deal sourcing
don't stop don't stop what do you mean
by that what
what um i mean in
i think it was december 15th i didn't
have money to pay rent
um do you know what you know the three
thousand pound deal that i refunded the
first one i sold
yeah i was i think that was the last
month of rent that i had
uh and i struggled to sell deals for a
while after that and i
hit literally rock bottom and then i
started this year with
you know all these deals sold so yeah
just don't quit
that's the best thing you came around my
house a couple months ago
yeah october 7th what's that
october 7th october the 7th was it good
was it a good day
it was brilliant oh yeah honestly like
when you walked in the room
i i didn't feel i haven't felt like that
since i saw ed sheeran in concert
honestly
because i followed you so much
beforehand you know
i felt like a little girl inside man ed
sheeran
is much more talented and famous than i
am but he won't help you make as much
money as i'll help you make sure
exactly man exactly man that's great
that's great
so so um a couple questions are coming
up for you as well right now
uh someone said why did the deal have to
be refunded so if maybe you could just
tell us a little bit about
why you funded what happened just in a
in a nutshell that'd be really helpful
yes so uh basically we had a quote for
260
000 for the property um we told him it
was 290 for like a 10
contingency and uh he took he's got his
own development team he's a
you know quite a big developer and um
yeah he's got his own development team
and he went down there and he priced it
up for about four hundred thousand
um and there was a couple of other
things like uh one of the walls
uh so this was a deal that was brought
to me by another member of the academy
gratiella yeah and uh yeah
she went down there with him showed him
showed him around did all all the sales
stuff and it was it was really good but
um
you just found a couple of problems and
the pricing and you just thought
because it's not a booming market it's
not worth the risk at the moment
you know yeah so uh yeah he just yeah
ask for a refund
and uh give back to him the next day
fair enough and if someone does that if
someone buys a deal
and the following day they're changing
their mind they're getting cold feet or
there's some issues
you're always best off to just refund
them you know rather than trying to hold
on to the money and creating
and creating um you know bad well bad
blood
because you know ultimately you're going
to resell the deal or you're going to
find the investor another deal
um obviously there's terms if they come
back to you after two months
actually i changed my mind that's a
different story um tom do you what do
you give you investors do you give them
like
in the t's and c's do you have um like a
14-day calling period or something
yeah a 14-day refund uh in this case it
was
um i mean yeah it was basically
dependent on the planning permission
being granted but yeah 14-day refund is
standard
that's fine awesome great stuff well hey
keep up the great work
and if there's anything you need give us
a shout i want to get anthony up on the
call in a minute and although anthony
looks like he's doing deals
um anthony wilmot i think he's doing i
think he's doing deals so i'll get him
up i've been with anthony wilmer
all day and um we've been we've been
actually we actually found a piece of
land today
which um which is located walking
distance from my house where i live
so i'm really excited about that um all
right anyone wants to jump on while
we're waiting for anthony and
give me some news tell me what you've
done thank you guys
yeah go ahead um hello guys how you
doing um
good news not as great as others in the
sense of the deal
i'm just getting started um i've
was supposed to have had my first
viewing today but i've got it tomorrow
the viewing today was cancelled by the
landlord
and he said listen he said listen i've
been i've heard it all before
tell me what you do i have 50 flats that
are empty
and i'm willing to do business so give
me an email and tell you what you do
tell me what you do
so that's just a potential lead there i
have my first viewing tomorrow
and um after meeting people from samuel
365
i've got two business partners and we're
getting into a rent to run business
together so
i just feel like it's progressing action
equaling
massive results kabir that's awesome
thank you
over the next couple days this week
thank you thank you hopefully
i want to keep in touch with this
landlord hopefully i have much
more news for you guys and next week
hopefully there's a very big update
that's awesome you know what i think is
really important as well like
on these calls i want to hear people i
want to hear from people that are
struggling
and i want to give them some advice and
help them out and coach them i also want
to hear from people that are women
and i wanna i know i think it's
important wednesday is a celebration day
for me
so it's important to celebrate those
that are winning and also be inspired
um and of course throughout the whole
week 365 days a year i tell you
something did you know this
on christmas day christmas
day last month on christmas day some of
our mentors
were giving up their christmas morning
to speak to samuel 365 members
there was samuel 365 members i.e you
guys
on christmas day booking calls i mean
what are you doing it's crazy
um i don't but but i'll tell you
something you know that's how much we we
um
you know we value you guys as part of
the property
family as part of the samuel 365. it's
called samuel 365 because
you've got stuff you can do the training
the calls
365 days of the year so um you know
kabir
great work keep it up and looking
forward to next week
all right anyone want to share anything
um i'm i'm ready
oh yeah go ahead go ahead hold on for a
second um i think we've got
uh camille camille go ahead good evening
how are you okay
yes awesome yeah great great so i want
to share a little success
story uh if i can yeah so um
last month i was chasing a local uh guy
he's a
it's a direct vendors deal um he was an
owner of the uh
shop the travel agent shop and it's a
freehold property
and obviously because of kobe did
everything he was struggling with his
business and now he was uh he posted on
gumtree
and so i approached the guy and i had
like
three viewings on it and we uh we made
an offer on it um
which was i think in my opinion it's a
good deal i know the area because
it's in my hometown so that's great uh
but yeah pretty much he uh he offered
the uh
the asking price was 85 and i think the
asking price was pretty much the market
value
of it yeah i managed to get that secured
for 73 and a half
and that is as i say it's a commercial
property um
so yeah we're going to convert that into
a wombat apartment
and we're going to rent it out so it's
going to be a bit of like a combination
between brr
and conversion from commercial to
residential property
i also do that with the with the jv
partner which is which is going to be my
first jv partnership
which is exciting um
and yeah it's it's it's going to be a i
hope a good deal
i think the gdv i
i was kind of like uh conservative on it
because
when i spoke the estate agent they told
me roughly between 115
220 the final value so i put that down
as
105 just to be safe and secure um
and yeah the the relief we it is going
to be about 16 000
so uh putting all the figures together
we won't be able to put all the money
out we're going to leave some money in a
deal
uh but it's still giving us a good um a
good return on investment
and it's obviously one of the things
then so you see
offer accepted of 73 you say 73 and a
half yes
73 and a half why did you offer 73 and a
half
that was the agreed price so i
first i i offered a little bit less and
then he was obviously wanted to get a
little bit more
uh and then we met at that price love it
love it
73 and a half how much is the refurb uh
16 grand
16 grand and then what's the what's the
gdv uh 105.
105. so i mean that's a conservative
number but
uh yeah okay so you'll make about you'll
make about 15 16 000 pounds
in profit and then you'll refinance
and you'll probably you'll probably pull
out what maybe
80 percent of your money you might leave
in sort of 15 grand or so
so really solid really really really
solid
you join venturing with it so you're not
putting in your own money which again is
is is is incredible what do you do for a
living come out
uh i'm a production engineer in the
aerospace
business aerospace company cool cool
it's just great to see so many people
doing you know finding brr deals
um you know there are deals out there
right now so again top tip would you say
to someone
looking to find either to find a deal i
mean you found a deal and a joint
venture partner
which is which is incredible so top tips
looking for someone somewhat someone
looking to do the same what would you
say
i would say um keep looking on the
market deals as well as of the market
you know there are deals you know on
gumtree on uh
on facebook you know just keep looking
and trying different sources not just
don't stick to the right although you
know there are deals everywhere
and yeah just disconnect with people
because you never know who's gonna
who's gonna be able to sort of you know
connect with you at that point when you
need somebody somebody can just connect
with you and then
they can be prepared to actually put the
money down for you so uh
incredible incredible hey massive
congrats from myself from the samuel 365
team
i'm going to get mark parham up he's put
his hand up he's always got something
important to say
so mark what is up brother well the ons
has announced that we've got record
highs on property prices so that's
pretty good news right
yeah i mean but yeah in terms of what
i've been doing
um i have done my first jv
with my mum who is very anti doing
property
so i will run you through the figures
very briefly um
it's actually the family home so it's
currently worth 750 000 we have got
plans in place
um which have they got to be amended
slightly i spoke to the planners this
week so it got declined but with some
amendments it's going to go through
um the build cost is going to be 500 000
and the end value will be between 2 and
2.2 million
so there's about a 750
000 pound profit on that and my mum is
the most
anti-mortgage person in the world this
will be a no money down deal because
we're going to mortgage her property to
fund for the
renovation so it'll be zero money in
um but you have no idea how long it's
taken me to get her to agree
to do anything so um this has taken
three months for the plans
but about three years as a lead
where is it mark and what is it it's in
oxfordshire and
it's a four bedroom house at the moment
on about a half a plot acre plot
and it's going to be an eight bedroom
house um
all six en suites
cinema room um there's going to be a gun
cabinet shelter underneath with wine
cellar and all this sort of stuff
you're just refurbing an existing house
you're not no no no no no
big extension three three and a half
thousand foot
extension great so big big
big bit more than double that this is
the problem with the planners they
didn't like the fact that it was more
than double
yeah so we had to scale it back by about
a fifth um but not too much not too much
they were impacted on the end value
or or anything like that so i've spoken
to some of the agents and got some ideas
but yeah no been been been a good week
for that i think
you know what just to say as well about
to add on to what mark's saying
like mark's doing this deal which is
gonna make him you know
three quarters of a million pound profit
which is incredible um
however that's that stuff you build up
to
you know when when i sorry i'd also like
to add that that took three years to get
my mum to agree to it
yeah i haven't tried this for one week
i've been trying this on for three four
years
three four years ago like i anyone that
doesn't know mark i sold mark a deal i
packaged and sold him at hmo
maybe three or four years ago now or
even longer i don't remember but in
airfield okay and um and and marcus
slowly over the years you know built his
portfolio he's now working on bigger
development stuff
and that's the progression i always i
always say
don't don't do it your next deal should
always be bigger than your last deal
you know you should always because it
takes just as much effort
to make 75 grand as it does to make 750
grams
it really frigging does camille
is about to make 15 16 grand on a little
deal joint venture none of his own money
guaranteed he'll spend just as many
hours on that as mark will spend making
7.50 now am i saying that camille
shouldn't do the small deal
no he needs to do the small deal to
build his experience
his confidence his competence his
mortgage ability all kinds of stuff and
you're gonna
you're always gonna mess up on your
first deal i'd rather mess up on a small
deal
than on a big deal so you just want to
build up to it advice for someone
starting out wanting to get into maybe
development side of things
so this is my first one obviously in
terms of development everything else has
been like by refurbished refinance
and hmos so i i i followed your advice
it i started small
my first hmo was a hundred grand then
150 then 350
then 500 um and it scaled up from there
so
i i think your advice is really solid
you know start start small
and work your way up um and you also
gain more um
[Music]
more gravitas right you can speak from
experience when you're talking to people
at a higher level my mum only believes
me today because she's seen what i've
done before
so true right she wouldn't believe me
when i first met you
she if i'd said i met this guy on the
internet he's told me that this is a
really good idea
let's mortgage your house which you
spent
40 years paying off and your husband's
just died
let's do that because my dad passed away
just around the same time
and you know she would never have heard
me out there
there would have been no chance so it's
learning when's the right time
to start you know what well i love what
you've said as well there because
you know people love to try and a lot of
um
non-successful people negative people
they love to try and discredit
what successful people are doing so they
might say to mark oh if only
my mom had that kind of money or oh it's
all right
they'll say that but here's the thing if
if the people that say that if their mom
did have that money
there was no way they would invest it in
them yeah yeah
so so it's like like evans evans is on
the court evans willie
people people said oh his dad joint
ventured with him well firstly he was
his girlfriend's dad
and secondly before he went through my
training
they're in a cat in hell's chance his
girlfriend's dad
would have given him a hundred thousand
pounds like it wouldn't have happened
his girlfriend was very risk-averse he
had to present an actual
business plan he had to know his stuff
so as you as you become
as you become more competent what
happens is you become more investable
and you want to become investable and
the only way you're going to be able to
do that is by demonstrating that you
know how to invest so you need to be
faithful with the little that you've got
and then you'll be trusted with more
it's a biblical principle
and it's true for this business as just
about anything
and the other thing i'd like to say
thank you to you for you gave me a shout
out last week for my youtube channel
and i'm now 180 subscribers so you know
some of my subs are on here so thank you
so much for subscribing
that's great i'm so pleased with this
community we support each other you know
thank you so much guys youtube adding
lots of value
uh did a really nice review for me on
youtube as well
off the back of the crash course and um
yeah and i'm really glad to have you on
the 365 mark it's great to have people
of
you know people that are just starting
out and it's also great to have people
that have been in the game a long time
like yourself
so uh no thank you so much for learning
and i'm still learning you know i had a
good call with patricia
and um i think i i put her in touch with
somebody that
that could help her with something but
she's teaching me things right she's got
she's brave she's going out and doing
big deals
and she's just just getting started so
yeah she's inspirational to me as well
and it reminds me that i need to push
myself a bit more as well when i see
that
hey mark thank you so much thank you so
much um
chris harris has got his hand up um i
know chris i was with chris just i think
it was the day before yesterday i was
with chris in person
see i'll meet you guys in person as well
you know you guys
i do meet with you folks in person uh
chris did you want did you want to jump
on
yeah cheers uh well done mark when
everybody who's spoken so far
some incredible deals like what a night
it is tonight to be on this call
yeah um can i just say as well patricia
and also gemma edens
like and camille as well and some others
on the call
like what uh an inspiration it is to be
in contact with these people
um they've driven me over the last week
they've helped me they've supported me
they've been on facebook on calls
um like they're amazing and they're
gonna absolutely smash it samuel
um so it's it's a real privilege to be
to be uh working alongside them as well
um thanks to you and tony on monday i've
cut
a lot of the excuse express and cut the
crap um i've actually packaged two deals
thanks to your advice on uh
on that hmo with kind of delaying
completions and clauses and things like
that
i've packaged two deals uh one of them
has gone out tonight for investors
um so i'm hoping to source that by the
end of the week the other one has
actually been taken by a relative of
mine
and when i was running the figures he
said what are you doing
i ran him through the figures and he's
like do you have to source both of those
or i said i'd rather join venture one
and he said well let's have a let's have
a talk about this so he's actually
sending me proof of funds tomorrow
so i'm going to source one and join
adventure one both off the team
you know what as well just like chris
has been in this community for many many
months
but it took coming to my house yeah
to really get results he came to my
house two days ago
paid 500 pounds and um and literally
you know and i even got his i'll even
show you i'll need to show you
you know what this is whilst he's off uh
thank you to tony if you're on the
call as well tony quirk um thank you
very much for your support on monday it
was incredible
i can't find your business plan but it's
somewhere it's somewhere
i don't know where it is but it's
somewhere around the house samuel um
do you mind me asking just how do people
actually get involved
in your network how do i get involved in
my idea yeah how do people get involved
in your network i've seen a lot of
people have gone through your training
gone through your courses
and you've almost taken taking them
under your wing [ __ ]
how did they actually get you involved
in your network your people around you
yourself
yeah that's a really good question i
think i think the best way
is to get my and not just mine but get
people's attention and the way you get
people's attention is by taking action
and getting results success breeds
more success and what happens is like
you you get a little deal like camille's
got a little deal now
in fact look at this next week let me
tell you what my diary is
okay so on tomorrow
tomorrow sorry tomorrow i'm running a
discovery day at my house friday
i'm going to go meet up with a lady
called hannah mills hannah mills is part
of my academy
she's financially free i'm going to
spend the day with her
right no charge or anything i'm not
she's not paying me
i'm just going to go and spend the day
with her because she freaking rocks
um then on monday
i'm going to go meet jl spooner she's
also on my academy
she's um financially free already she's
absolutely rocking it she's picking up
keys to a new property on monday
yeah actually i just want to be there
for her today did you really i just
wanted yeah um
in terms of she said she wanted to help
people get involved in rent to rent
yeah and i sent her a message she
responded and we had a quick talk
and yeah
he's um he's building his own house i'm
gonna go meet him like
i just love being around people that are
taking action and stuff travel i'm
getting your attention now
i want to get involved in my network
dude you've got viewings and stuff
you've got you've got you just said
you've got viewings you've got stuff
going on
give me a challenge if be a challenge
however hard it may be and i want to
accomplish that challenge and get
be part of the network
well go make some money come on the call
next week and say hey i did some
viewings and guess what i sold something
to make two grand
okay all right okay all right that's
interesting
everybody on the call it's it's you know
i mean you can come on these calls and
receive a bit of inspiration and
motivation or whatever
but it's really what happens in between
these calls you know that that really
that really makes things happen so
that's awesome camille um
i've also got a guy um who you may know
he's got his hand up at the moment
his name is evans willie evans do you
want to jump on and say something and
she's done
evans yes how's everyone doing
yeah we're super good yes can you hear
me yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's always good to be part of the
community really like to help people and
to see
people starting scratching winning uh
this week has been very very good
uh for the last two weeks i've been only
focusing on
doing my rent to rent and get attendance
even getting a refund but
from monday actually went out to the
deal association uh
and obviously i secured two two rent to
rent to hmos in northampton to eight
beds
uh i've got a few investors looking at
it so that's obviously um
only going through hasn't been sold yet
also secured another
uh eight bed in liverpool as well uh
rented hmo
slash essay um and i've also got an
individual just signed onto a baseball
sourcing today
i'm actually going out to uh going up
north tomorrow uh
going to um staffordshire and stuff to
find a few
bro deals um i've also secured another
joint venture partner
who's willing to put all the money in
just go find the right deal hopefully
i'll find it tomorrow
who is that day so again who is the
person the other joint venture partner
uh you don't know his name is joseph he
owns uh he owns a big company
uh um in london um nice
yeah so uh so yeah so
is killing it you probably you probably
saw evan's financial freedom challenge
we did that last month
he went from 23 pounds in his pocket to
10 000 pounds
he went from sleeping on his
girlfriend's dad's single bed
thing whatever broke ass to living in a
penthouse in london in canary wharf
with the skyline views and stuff secured
a what a 100 000 pound joint venture
now he's doing more bigger deals and
stuff literally within the space of a
month
so get rich quick is not a thing but get
results
quick is get results quick if you're not
planning on getting results quick then
you may as well just quit
because there's you know this is not
university where you go to university
for four years and then you go and get a
job
you've got to be earning and learning at
the same
time so you know you should be doing
deals
whilst you're learning so evans is
absolutely inspirational to see what
you've done
now i did spend a whole seven days with
evans evans
in those seven days was i focused on you
solely or was i doing other stuff
uh you were you gave me all of your
attention for seven days
you stealed it you still did it you
still in one call
which is the wednesday call uh can you
give me all your attention
that's true so the only thing i did
during that whole seven days was this
call that's how i committed that to you
guys
after that evans had 24 7
we literally slept in the same little
area
we were like we were like together until
we were falling asleep
then the first thing in the morning bang
hitting the phones working out bums off
so evan's super super good one piece of
advice people on the court what are you
gonna say
uh anyone on the call i would say just
get trained just get knowledge because
the only difference
with me now to me you know years ago or
months ago or weeks ago
even was the knowledge that i have now
and the community that i'm part of um
if i had that knowledge in a community
you know a few months or a few years ago
may i would have changed my life a big
time so uh what i've seen
um in this community the knowledge that
i have
like i just don't feel like the same way
again so anyone on this call
uh you know seeing this for the first
time my advice to you is
it's worth getting knowledge and being
part of the community because the doors
that's open for me
is crazy man so uh so that's my advice
dude that's awesome
get stick around the community also i'd
say don't just don't just
dip in and dip out of these calls every
so often i would really encourage you to
be on
if you're on every single call like this
what are they called
i don't know wednesday coaching call
whatever we should call it a winner's we
should call it a winner's webinar i
reckon but anyway
um but you know what if you're on every
one it's going to give you it's going to
give you inspiration
it's going to give you accountability
you're going to have opportunities to
ask questions if you get stuck
and also network great place to network
and every single person that's jumping
up and speaking up and shouting
and talking about their success there's
131 people on this call
that are going to be able to see you and
what you're doing not just 131 people
but 131 serious people so
you know the opportunities are
incredible so evan absolutely awesome
i need to get emma on the call as well i
know emma calling's on the call
sorry i'm losing my voice um emma what's
what's good what's happening
okay i'm just i'm here to myself hi
everybody hey you
you sent me the sweetest video ever um
so i just want to hear about what's
happening what's going down right now
um a lot is going on for me right now um
so i've just
i'm waiting on sales to go through for
two bio refurbished refinance projects
um both are three bedroom two six bed
hmos
in manchester um one of them
is a no money down deal i've raised the
finance for and
the other i'm going to do a jv um with
somebody on the
academy with and so i've got that going
on
i've got three essays which are full
right up until
april for contractors i've just opened a
cleaning business in manchester
and specializing for in the service
accommodation community
and i've got an estate agency that went
live two weeks ago
and i found two lan deals today
which are direct to um the owners as
well so i've got loads going on
my goodness by the way who doesn't know
emma
emma's actually one of our one of our
mentors on samuel 365
um she's been on the academy now for i
don't know a couple years at least
built up a very nice property
profitable property portfolio consisting
of all kinds of different
things specializing in service
accommodation
uh now doing development deals and
honestly emma you are
an absolute light a diamond i mean i
message emma
probably once a week i'll just message
her you know check in or even if it's
just like
i'll drop her a voice tonight tell her
what i've been doing that week or what
deals i got going on
and um you know it's just so so good to
know you and to
to have you as um as as not only as a
student but now as a friend and as a
mentor
so um biggest piece of advice to someone
wanting to just get results this year
2021
and just give it your absolute all um
and don't make any excuses for yourself
i'm a single parent i've got a crazy
little three-year-old
and you know i've done it all by myself
with the support of the academy so if
you've got the willpower and you've got
the knowledge
just put them together and anything is
possible and
like i sent some i put a post up on
instagram last week and
i'm not joking i nearly i actually did
have a cry and
because it's only been 18 months ago i
left my career
and i had to pinch myself walking into
my house because i sourced a development
for
a client um and
like i'm still in awe of the whole thing
right now because my life has actually
changed and
i always thank samuel like i'm always
say i i o every time i see him i'm like
thank you
my advice is just work hard network with
the people within this community because
it will change your life that's so good
and emma as well i mean
obviously everything that emma's built
up is a direct result of her persistence
emma is one of the most persistent
people that you'll meet when the going
gets tough emma keeps
going and um you know i'm really honored
to have been able to coach you and get
you into it
and now it's great to see that rippling
effect as you now mentor people
um you know throughout samuel 365 and
also throughout the academy
so massive inspiration emma thank you so
much for
sharing thomas thomas um kalan
has been has been had his hand up for a
while he's messaging
i'm like that please please what's wrong
brother well i've just literally i just
started yesterday
so literally watched your video on
youtube was so
inspired literally taken aback by what
you've done for these people just off
your own back i just think it's
absolutely amazing um so i've literally
been going around speaking to agents and
copied some of what you've done on
youtube
and like taking it to the next extreme
so i've already got an investor
i've already got about three deals and
so i'm already going going going going
going so it's really really helped and
the training's been fantastic i've been
watching you
you're training on the computer
literally all day
yeah but what training is that is that
the deal finally extrapoganza uh
yeah yeah the deal will find nick's
seven games for the record i'll just say
this
the deal finding extravaganza the never
use your own money again program all
these training courses they are included
in samuel 365.
so you know yes we have the academy and
we do have some advanced training
where you come around the house and
everything's like that but just to
samuel 365 for not for the 95 pound a
month subscription
you have so much training so much
content so much support
so much unlimited one-on-one calls so
you know don't um
don't don't necessarily think that just
because you're not necessarily on the
academy or whatever you can't
you can't really get going and do stuff
like you can
and of course you know we have the
academy there for people that can afford
it for people that need that extra
further training
but just as a samuel 365 member you know
you can fly and i'm wanting to get i
want to get some
we started samuel 365 last year we
launched i think around about the
springtime
of 2020 and when we used to have these
calls
there was like 15 people and everyone
was
like brand new to property and it's just
for me it's so
awesome seeing now within like nine
months
we've now got 130 people on the call and
everyone's coming not
necessarily even saying i'm stuck i'm
struggling asking questions coming
because they just want to share their
successes
and celebrate that and to me that's just
i'm just gassed to see that so
you know massively massively um loving
this so thomas what can i do for you and
what do you think
how do you get through the seven day
challenge with you how how is that
doable
how can i do that i yeah okay
so the seventh the seven day financial
freedom challenge
um the first time i ever did it with
someone
someone just rocked up at my crash
course a guy called glenn
and basically pitched that he wanted to
do it with me
um a thousand people in the room peer
pressure
everything and you know and that was
that was the first one now after that
i started getting bombarded with people
requesting to do the financial freedom
challenge with me
to the point where i just couldn't i
just couldn't like um
you know smartphone just said get ready
for a thousand pictures that's what
happened
when people saw that so that's why i
created the eviction
and the eviction is like a tv show
and what happens on the eviction is you
spend a month living with me
eviction a couple months ago and it's
like the apprentice so
you go through challenges there'll be
ten people on the eviction
you apply to be on the eviction and it
just depends on you your energy your
commitment
we have it once a year and the person
that gets through and shows they're the
strongest contestant on the eviction
i go and move into their house so last
year
we did the eviction the top three
finalists i agreed to go moving all of
their houses the first one was with
evans it was an absolute success
the second one was with lawton to be
honest it was a disaster i did it last
week
it was a disaster i am going to publish
i am going to publish it
um on youtube all the same emma was
really helpful but even emma couldn't
help me out she was like dude you're on
your own on this one
um now we did make money there were some
successes but he did not become
financially free
um um but there were some there were
some wins
so that i'm going to be on the second of
uh february and i'm supposed to be going
to ireland
i was supposed to be going next week to
ireland with uh david david's on the
call
but i just couldn't face doing another
financial freedom challenge next week
after the disaster of last week so i
told david he used to just be patient
with me and let me just
rebuild my confidence you know okay okay
i know i understand i've just seen it it
was kind of all weird i'm into the
secret so i'm into all like the universe
and how things work
and like it was weird i'd watch this
thing with assad asset academy
and was like he's a bloody nightmare i
can't go with him and then literally
your video came up within seconds i was
like i've got to look at property
marketing videos
i've got because i don't come from this
background i come from the sales
background but i come from
predominantly like an executive
assistant personal assistant
but i've always done sales and i've
always done property i've always worked
with property men
with property people like working like
directors from country wire directors
from um
lots it's always been like pace property
which is a small one in south end where
i'm originally from
so it's those sort of people that i'm
used to working with so i was like oh
let me just go and let me just have a
little
try and actually i knew my personality i
don't care about picking up the phone i
tell people to pick up the phone
i say pick up the phone and speak to
people build your network
speak to people build a relationship
build rapport
and i do that all the time anyway if you
combine
thomas if you combine your energy and
passion and
sales and people skills with razor sharp
property knowledge and the numbers and
the number crunching you're going to
freaking blow and i'm pumped and gas to
see your results so keep us posted
on here next week all right i think
there's a couple people as well i've got
the hands up i think khloe
chloe fear has got a hand up um and then
also
michael ball if you wanted to just jump
on and and uh
you know go ahead and ask a question or
tell us what's good hey guys hey
yes yes yes so okay i've had a bit of a
bittersweet week this week
so i secured a really juicy really nice
deal
down here in bournemouth it's a nice
little two-bedroom house
with a view to using it as service
accommodation i've got a fantastic
service accommodation management company
in place
who have done a full feasibility report
on the property and it you know
the return on investment is around sort
of 22
so it's really really decent deal
however
uh the problem then came i knew that i
could originally i knew i could get the
finance for it but because recently i've
been furloughed i now
can't raise the finance in the normal
way so i don't know any of you guys i'm
now thinking about possibly
maybe selling the deal so i don't know
if any of you guys want to perhaps co
deal source but yeah i've got obviously
all the details i've done all the due
diligence on it
um it really stacks it's a great deal so
yeah like let me know if any of you guys
might be interested
back it in the chat whack it in the chat
and then people will get in touch if
they want to code
your source incredible thank you so much
great to have you on the call
graziella i need to hear from you what's
happening
um sorry i wasn't a phone call with an
investor
but i don't know it's supposed to be a
really good one but with one of those
try to get the property address it's
like no it's not going to happen
from you i know you've had some crazy
success
i'm not getting anybody about it because
i know that it's been a little bit kind
of confidential because you've not
but but what are you able to say right
now
uh i don't know there is a lot of work
by so rewarding
it really works it didn't even know
existed a job like
property source and some investors you
have to educate they don't really know
but some generally they want to see just
the document to see how it works you
know how we work
what you know what they sign for a lot
of people they wear a lot of investors
uh and then really interesting even when
you sell indeed
the beautiful thing is the other
investors
is like you give a kid the candy and
then you take it out
so they come back to you oh my god i
miss on the day like
you give me two hours just wait
that is such a powerful thing that you
just said there i don't think people
even would have got that so let me say
it again
like what what grazier is saying is when
you first sell a deal
and it feels like oh there's not really
that many people interested
and it feels tougher then when you sell
it other people come and go
hey is the deal still available and you
go now it's calm and what happens is you
create a sense of urgency
and then what happens is very quickly
when you package and sell a deal it goes
in minutes
what's the highest fee if you're allowed
to say that you've charged on selling a
deal so far
okay how many zero does he well still
i'm checking how many zeros go uh
yes god now wait
uh it's got one two three four five
it's got five numbers
like five c like so that means that
means it's more than ten thousand
that's and that's absolutely incredible
so graziella you know what i love about
you more than anything
i love your massive energy and passion
so
you know thank you for being a regular
part of the community same with gemma in
fact
gemma can you have you got anything you
want to say i know you always do i've
just muted you
oh hey you're right what's happening i
mean i've just got out the shower said
no judgment here because i'm probably on
a big screen
um since last week well i actually lost
my job last week
yes yeah so i've been i've been with the
engineering company for five years as a
project manager and
uh got served two weeks notice last week
so next week is my last week
crazy i am i don't think i'd have ever
left that's the thing you know what i
mean like
yeah i wanted to do full-time property
sourcing and i don't think i would have
ever left because it was a security
um but you know what i'm actually really
excited now so
yeah in the last week um i'm just
getting a
one of my deals through finance at the
moment through bridging
and that was a conversion from a four
bedroom to a seven bedroom hmo
um that i sold and up sold uh
what did i sell uh project management as
well fifteen hundred
so total was six thousand five hundred
for that
um i offered a lease option agreement on
a nine hundred thousand pound house that
they're just thinking about that's a
conversion of a commercial to
residential
property so all we'd need is to raise
the finance
uh for the refurbishment um
so yeah it's been uh it's been a bit of
a crazy week
but hopefully it's gonna be amazing once
i'm
full and you know what though if if
you'd have lost your job a year ago
maybe you'd have been in a very
different situation and felt very
differently about it but
now you've got your your property stuff
coming in and you're dealing sourcing
and your different things
i guess now it's almost an exciting
thing to have been made
yeah well i think my plan is now to earn
more money than the ceo of my company so
i can
turn up in a ferrari and go hey you know
you let me go
powerful motivator sorry mark what
spite is a powerful motivator no isn't
it just
you know you know what and i'll tell you
something though um there was a part of
me when i was starting out because i'm
you know you know my story i'm from
working class background kind of failed
in school
um no one thought i'd really amount to
anything and there was a part of me in
the first few years where i was kind of
like yeah screw you what happens is that
that might be a motivating fact in the
early days as you begin to get
more and more successful the only
motivating factor is going to be love
and helping other people and i know
i know that that's already there for you
and um you know so really really really
pleased to see you winning
best piece of advice you'd say to
someone on the call right now before i
get anthony wilmar on the call
um okay so best piece of advice would be
to
um add value to everybody's
um post on facebook and in groups and
i'm going to just give you a very very
quick example here
so somebody put in your you know your
365 and
now you sum your leads property
investors group
somebody said let's see how switched on
everybody is uh work out how much cash
flow i'm gonna get
next per month loads of people had
commented but nobody had got the actual
answer right and i commented and got the
answer right
and i have got a solid investor that has
won in three
um properties this year he saw my answer
and contacted me straight away and said
gemma i see your answer
because i said i always say to my
investors where did you where did you
find me
and he said i saw your answer uh to one
of the posts on there
and told me which post it was and um and
i was like oh brilliant
and uh he says yeah i liked the fact
that you knew what you was talking about
so now i've got a
investors with samuel leeds get on there
get active
be positive there's a lot of negative
people on that group it's crazy because
it's my group
but it's there's a lot of people out
there like oh this doesn't work or
it's so it's like you know get out but
there's but there's also a lot of people
watching
so many people watching there's always
people watching what you're doing so
yeah they might they might put laughing
face to that comment
because it's funny but then i'm gonna
put money into a joint venture
so gemma that's absolutely awesome great
job good to see you on the call
just did my conversation real quick as
well i am gonna get
um uh anthony michael ball what's
happening hey sam
samuel um you might remember me from the
january
deals uh crash course we roleplayed and
you smashed that you smashed out that
role play
thing at the crash course i remember it
so um
i've come up i've come a bit further
from then i put on
the facebook group saying i need some
investors for
any interesting deals in humberside and
lincolnshire and one of the investors
is on the call now i'm not going to name
him because i don't think that's cool
colin's turn out but i'm so pleased to
see he's done here and
i had a role play with him he caught me
up in the supermarket and we were
chatting
and i think it was good you're the train
you gave me and the way to
just listen and talk and understand what
they want not try and sell what i have
was helpful so hopefully
after this course finished i'll be
giving this gentleman a deal that i
think will he'll like
and um yeah hopefully it's
gonna be what he's looking for and
hopefully um
it will it will be what we want so um to
and on monday i had some great deals but
i didn't have any investors so i put it
on the
facebook group and three people
gave me text and emails and calls just
to say
what have you got tell me about it and
uh and yeah and that took me from being
just bobbing along like is this the
right thing for me to
going to do a job that i don't really
like project manager or whatever
but boom i'm here right at the top of
the scale we'll put 11.
and it's actually it works the facebook
looks really positive and
it is it is put things on there people
it's yeah
it is and also as well just just just to
kind of add to that
um if you post a deal on the facebook
group it will not be approved
because you can't you can't sell on the
facebook group unless you've
um you know got a private arrangement
okay with without company
so as gem as gemma did though what
gemma's doing is
she's adding value same as michael
adding value answering
and that that's what's going to win win
people's trust
it's not it's not spammy you're not
posting a deal
but you're just building relationships
and a good relationship is always better
than a good deal so michael
awesome stuff great great work keep it
up and i look forward to hearing from
you next week
awesome all right um anthony john could
you jump on a second
and say i've been with anthony all day
man hey how's it going
how many hours did we spend together
today today oh god what's up
get there 10 and we left about four so
we spent the whole day together i loved
it
amazing hours me and anthony looking at
deals
um it was a small group we were running
a little mastermind session
and um we found a piece of land today
what you've got going on yourself though
what's happening so
uh we're working on um for ourselves
personally we're working on three
developments currently this year
um so these are ones that are secured
that we're currently going through
planning or going through contracts with
and the gdp on these is
just under 9 million so some great
projects we're working on
um i literally secured another plot
yesterday
which um we're expecting that to have a
development value of about a million
but um i haven't decided whether we're
going to sell that one yet or whether
we're going to look for another joint
venture partner with it because we've
now got a lot of projects on and we
don't want to overdo
things but um you know development is
our key focus this year
i've literally stepped up a gear and um
you know we're just going for it full
force really
incredible man incredible and again
anthony
started off he joined the academy
started off on very very small deals
he was doing um rent to rent he started
doing
lit he started with no money started
doing little jv brr deals
and he slowly over the last couple few
years
built up to now doing these types of
development deals and and it comes with
time
and some people come to me like saying i
want to do i want to build houses i want
to buy a castle
i want to and it's like listen it comes
down i'm working on deal at the moment a
little extension i'm turning a two bed
into a four bed a little extension
gonna add about a hundred thousand
pounds profit onto it that's the kind of
stuff i'd recommend
starting with in development and then
just scale anthony's buying a property
at the moment
which is sounds i mean i've not seen it
yet but from the sounds of it
it's going to be like bigger than bigger
than anything
probably i've ever even invested in
myself it sounds like
humongous and awesome with a lot of
profit in it
um and anthony's also now one of our
mentors auntie what why did you become a
mentor
on samuel 365. what what made you do
that
you know what like obviously i love i
obviously came to tell
the world you to learn to be a speaker
to be a trainer so i could give back to
people because
i know when i started and there's lots
of people on this call who i've spoken
to
you know and even um just mark michael
just then
saying how excited he was to talk to you
i love that excitement because i know
when i started and i needed the help and
i know
you know getting around people like
yourself was exactly how
what's helped me get to where i wanted
to get to so now my mission
is now i've got to where i wanna i wanna
get to is to just give back to to
everybody else
you know and i've spoke to probably
about 50 of people on this call on the
samuel 365 coaching calls and
you know it's amazing to see you guys
tuning in to the wednesday webinar so
thank you for joining
um your engagement on the calls really
does make my day
you know and and i'm glad that i've been
able to give back to you guys so much
and
you know just listening to some of the
successes that people have done
i know that i might even have a little
bit of a hand in that just that little
piece of advice so that kick up the arse
just gives that somebody that motivation
and you're not getting this anywhere
else you're not getting the support from
anybody else and and that's what it's
all about
yeah absolutely and again like honestly
if you think how much it would cost to
get people like anthony individually
to mentor you and emma and this samuel
365
you have access at your fingertips to
book unlimited calls with me
anthony unlimited for 95 pound a month
this this
product and this service that we've
created you know is just like
honestly it's really unthinkable i mean
back in the day when i started
i wish i could have paid 95 pound a
month and just been able to at my
fingertips
because i can just speak i can just
speak to people that are doing
multi-million pound deals
you know all of our mentors are
financially free
uh yes we pay them we do pay them to be
a mentor we have to because everyone's
time is is valuable
but they're all financially free and
they do this from a position of service
and love
not because nurse's job they don't they
don't need to do this nancy definitely
doesn't need to do this he doesn't need
to be on this call right now but he is
because he wants to see other people win
and that's what this community is about
so as much as you're in
in samuel 365 to get you know if you
come
also to give and the people that are
winning the most like mark parham and
gemma and patricia
that they come to the community not not
not not the mindset of what can i get
but more than once
how can i bring value and as a result of
that they end up getting more because
you know um the more value you give um
what is it who wants to say if you want
to help if you want to get what you want
give other people what they want and it
will just happen so anthony
mad respect and super excited to be
working on some on some big deals and
working together so thank you so much
right we're gonna wrap up now because it
is after nine o'clock
unless um well let me see because
there's one person who's had their hand
up for absolutely ages so i have to have
to answer it let me see um
i'm gonna get fabio on and then listen
as i say we i do want to keep these to
an hour because i don't want people to
start thinking
oh man i don't know if i've got time to
go on the call because it goes on for
two hours
so i do want to keep these to an hour um
diversion every week
eight o'clock wednesday every week i'm
only not going to be on these calls if
i'm
unwell or if i'm traveling and if i am
then anthony or someone's going to leave
the call or maybe maybe patricia is
going to leave the call
um so if you haven't had your questions
answered tonight
book a mentor and call one on one where
we can work with you and help you it's
all included as part of samuel 365.
so um fabio did you want to jump on and
tell us what's happening
hi samuel hey what's happening
yeah how are you i'm really good i'm
pumped
um i just want to say i really want to
thank you i'm so nervous right now but
don't worry we're glad to see you and
excited to hear what what's happening
yeah i'm so i started like two weeks ago
and i was really inspired by
i woke up one day and i i was like i was
like you know what because i had no idea
i'm
only 17. i had no idea what i wanted to
do as my like career path
i just woke up one day and i wrote like
i just wrote something about property
and you were like the first person that
came
on and it was like your video about um
about how to like kind of get a
property on like without like less money
but yeah yeah and then kind of like
looked into your like instagram and i
emailed your team i just felt so
inspired after
um watching you i attended the crash
course and then
obviously i joined um samuel 365 and
ever since i've been like glued i've
been glued to
all your kind of your the
the deal finding extravaganza like
literally after straight after my
revision like i take a little break and
i'm
glued like on my bed doing all your
crash courses
i did your first um one in like four
days and i just feel like
it's just really like changed how i see
things and inspired me so much i want to
thank you
oh you know what it's such a pleasure
and i'm so so um you know
humbled to hear that and anything you
need from myself
or the team as a samuel 365 member do
not hesitate be that annoying person
keeps asking for help um and um you know
massive respect 17 years old
being on the court mad mad that's the
same age as me when i got started
and um you know really excited to see
your results so thanks so much for
sharing
i even spoke to anthony and he gave me
such good advice like i was really happy
i just spoke to him about like
around 5 45 and i was just like he was
just telling me like
i was even asking questions about like
how i should get started
and i was talking about like kind of
networking because i want to start
networking with and he was telling me
about
you know clubhouse that he was telling
me all about that i know
it was just really helpful and it was
really informative
that's awesome well listen we're here
for you and uh keep up the great work
yeah thank you so much would debbie like
if you could set me a challenge to do
today like what would you do like
something just yeah if i could take your
chances i would say
by the time we meet up next week i would
say go and review
three houses because the person that
views the most houses
wins yeah the thing with houses it's a
bit hard because i'm still a bit young
and i don't know how my mom feels about
kind of viewing houses right now like
how how do you
like advise me to get around that kind
of viewing houses because i feel like
i'm just still quite new to this yeah
okay so what so
so so number one you've got 130
people on this call who are your network
of investors yeah you might be 17
but meeting you and talking to you on
the phone you could be 23.
yeah okay so when you ring up an agent
to book a viewing on a dick you know how
to find deals because you're on samuel
365 you've got access to the deal
finally stuff against the crash course
that never you should remember to get
broken you know how to do it
yeah just literally ring up an agent in
your area
find a decent deal ring them up book a
viewing the property market's open
book a viewing and if i go oh you know
just remember
you're part of a network of 130
investors yeah
over you three houses even if they're
terrible houses don't even see it as a
viewing see it as an appointment with an
estate agent to talk about what's going
on investment wise in the area
and then report on what happens and
believe me results will start to pick up
that's my advice
and if you're not happy with it just
tell her that you're doing a paper round
[Laughter]
work is business right yeah it's work
it's business the property market's
still open
thank you so much samuel you're really
really really welcome
um guys massive massive pleasure
mike kelsey i've just unmuted him
because i think he wanted to say
something about how he found his vr idea
he wanted to brag about his deals
so go on mike i'm not here to perhaps be
honest
one thing i wanted to mention was the
lease option boot camp
i've done over the last couple of days
with patricia has been amazing
alistair and ricky did an incredible job
it was just
you know they keep you get keep the
energy up it was just
amazing the day just flew by so and i've
learned so much so i just want to
do a shout out for those guys because
they're amazing amazing
we have the best trainers and mentors
on the planet on samuel leads training
you should
those guys should be teaching all the
other type of businesses
how to teach because i've been in lots
of courses when i worked in the offshore
industry and
i fell asleep enough for them i couldn't
and with this because it was just
so energetic the energy is just
incredible
no one trains up no one trains what we
train and no
technology or the heart to help people
like we have so thank you for being part
of the community thank you being on the
academy mike
god bless thank you thank you you're
very welcome you're very very welcome
um guys massive pleasure it is now nine
minutes past nine
um if you enjoyed being part of the
community sing
our praises on the on social media
on trustpilot on google reviews it
massively helps
um so please do that if you're a happy
customer let the world know we want to
grow the community
we want to help more people we want more
people to network with
and ultimately you know not only be
successful in property for ourselves but
also we want to help people because
money is
um a good tool that makes good things
happen so keep being generous
with your time with your knowledge with
your resources keep learning
keep learning and i'll look forward to
seeing you guys next week
bye guys
[Applause]
all alright everyone